[Music]
great because this is a great show and
i'm a great person i'm a great person
happy january 11th america
yes
january 11th just a year ago today it
was also january 11th
i know never forget so why is january
11th so important
because it's this great man's birthday
yeah
actor stuntman
little person
r.i.p felix scilla and if you don't know
who mr cilla is it's okay he was often
disguised as
cousin it in the addams family yeah
i know he was that guy
anyway it's his birthday that's why
january 11th is so important to me
another little person even though we
keep
stop it
but we keep being told the only day that
matters is january 6th what the
republicans are doing across the country
is really a
a legislative continua continuation of
what they did on january 6. wow well
then nan you got nothing to worry about
because as insurrections go that was a
bust
so what the hell is she talking about
and not i'm sure that could be qualified
as talking more like slurring with
punctuation
and whoever did her eyebrows should be
put in eyebrow prison
they're supposed to be lower than your
hairline
and what i better husband stock goes up
each time she mentions january 6th
she's as predictable as biden's three
o'clock nap
now we knew the january 6th anniversary
was a grift so in case you were one of
the gullible republicans who thought
january 6 was really about remembering
enjoy being patsies january 6 was a prop
just like cuomo's giant q-tip used to
vanquish political adversaries and help
the democrat party regain political
footing by rejiggering the rules see the
dems like to do politics the way ugly
people have sex
with the lights out
oh my god and they're going to use the
day to prevent rather than enhance
election transparency emily
no
like you care about ugly people
and liz and adam fell for it like biden
on a broken escalator
today president joe endorsed changing
senate rules regarding voting as dems
claim it's the biggest test of america's
democracy since the civil war but sorry
joe this isn't even the biggest test
since corn pop it's just hyperbole and
that's why they have to keep saying it i
mean no one needed convincing that 911
was bad a year later for january 6
however never forget means we all
literally would forget unless we make a
big deal out of it every year so now
it's january 6 every day as republicans
engage in extreme attacks on our most
basic constitutional right voting which
is why now joe pushes a filibuster carve
out which sounds like a new entree at
boston market
cat would know but now you see the point
of the january 6th anniversary the dems
need an emergency to change voting rules
it's 2020 all over again and like a
serial killer's dog the media happily
played along joining in on the
hysterical messaging yes the messaging
that's what it's all about these days
gee i wonder is the media out of touch
with people
a lot of the media does seem when i look
at it and then travel the country to be
very out of touch with people if you
travel the country people are not really
living in the same uh bubble that it
seems that uh most of the media is
messaging toward i think this is an
issue because if people are tuning out
uh what's going on in cable news if
we're not messaging toward uh the
general population um you know they're
just you know ignoring everything and
and living their lives uh and we're not
really getting the information that they
need to them
look at that
that's some hairless on hairless action
one more egg and we could have made an
omelette
oh my god cnn frets they don't live in
the same bubble as we do americans are
tuning out ignoring everything they're
going outside and talking to people some
of them are actually smiling
yeah americans are living their lives
and not listening to you you freaks and
cnn just found out now haven't they seen
their ratings are they too small to see
at this point also do you really believe
this hack travels outside the bubble i
bet his idea of seeing the country is
grabbing a connecting flight in
charlotte
but this is good news the messaging
isn't working no one listens to cnn's
conveyor belt of lies which makes sense
consider the sources chris cuomo don
lemon a guy who ate human brains a lady
who eats crickets on purpose
let's not forget tubin
we've been there and now there's john
griffin the longtime cnn producer an
alleged child trafficker who's been
named in a civil lawsuit alleging
despicable acts of horrific sexual abuse
between april and july 2020 griffin
allegedly invited three women and their
underage daughters
over for the purposes of sexual training
and that's according to the latest
federal indictment
yeah who knew cnn had its own in-house
jeffrey epstein and given the time frame
it seems like he was also violating
lockdown orders
there's a real outrage i wonder what's
on cnn now
it's ridiculous to say that we're out of
touch yeah i'm out of touch because my
pet iguana goes to private school come
on no we know what's going on all right
i know what the six flags is yeah when
y2k hits i'll be ready
i tip my guatemalan butler every time he
brushes my teeth yeah i mean i unadopted
my one-year-old son because he couldn't
spell green new deal and i always give
thumbs up to homeless people i mean even
in the winter when my thumb gets a
little cold you are an inspiration you
should be on good morning america
it's an interesting point so
so forgive us cnn if americans don't
really want any part of your messaging
you're kind of creeping us out at this
point you're the cable version of the
guy who hangs out at the playground but
didn't bring any kids and when you ask
him why he's there he says something
like hey i've always been fascinated by
the monkey bars
then you ask him which kid is his and he
says i wish they all were
maybe that's why cnn was so wrong on
kyle rittenhouse because by 17 they've
lost interest
but it's more than just their personnel
it's their hysteria conflict-based
profit model january 6 was just one
example while cnn and others gushed
endlessly about their own ptsd the rest
of america was like what
it's the same reliable hysteria they
applied to collusion covington kavanaugh
remember the classics that perfect phone
call was worse than watergate climate
change means the earth dies in eight
years january 6 is pearl harbor all over
again you see the disconnect between
them and you and it's this gulf between
their claims and actual reality that
mirrors exactly the gulf between the
press and the public they don't
understand and if you listen to cnn well
it's got to be america's fault even
though they've been so insanely wrong on
everything from covet to crime the last
time they were right wolf blitzer was a
mere pup
but you know maybe cnn should be
grateful no one is really paying
attention to them because if america did
imagine what else they'd find
welcome
tonight's guest
he may have lost the new york mayor's
race but he always wins our hearts
former gop candidate for new york mayor
curtis sliwa
she's living proof you could be a lawyer
and not a completely terrible person
outnumbered co-host emily compagno
she's cute astute and impossible to mute
fox business correspondent susan lee
[Applause]
and finally she's like the snow
cold white and found all over your
driveway in the morning
boxes contributor cat tim
[Applause]
emily good to see you and your hair
thanks
yes it's quite impressive that uh that
hair
you're the main yes you are the main
event um this is a natural response i
love watching cnn confused by why nobody
cares about their opinion after they've
been lying for five six seven years they
don't appreciate too that the chasm
between what they're putting out and
what normal americans are talking about
and how they think and feel is getting
wider by the day and to pile on you know
it's not just them just this week the
l.a times put out an article that said
mocking the deaths of those who are
unvaccinated was ghoulish but necessary
they said it was necessary to temper
vaccine skepticism this was a pulitzer
prize-winning columnist that we're
supposed to listen to that we are
supposed to make fun of those who have
died because of covet because they had
for whatever reason the the decision to
be unvaccinated and that same author by
the way during the trump administration
said that the emergency youth
authorization use authorization of the
vaccine was not to be trusted that it
might kill us and that that kind of bile
is being furthered by the media and he's
rewarded by a pulitzer and by
circulation when a normal american
grieves every death regardless if that
person has been vaccinated and we don't
take it upon ourselves to judge or to
enlighten someone that's someone's own
decision hmm well put young lady yes
she should be on tv
curtis how the cat's doing what do you
have 17 18. uh 16. unfortunately one of
my favorites hope passed to the
hereafter this past week so i've been
sitting shiva yeah really for the hope i
actually you know even when my mother
and father passed you know i'm supposed
to be the toughest guy in the world i
couldn't cry i cried three hours when
hope passed wow how old was hope hope
was actually eight but had a terminal
cancer my wife had rescued her two years
before from being euthanized destroyed
she had a great two-year run and every
night i come back from this umizerable
campaign of mine as a republican running
for mayor hope would always be there
nobody else would listen to me but hope
would be at my side there you
you go well are you hopeful about the
state of america you laughing at my
transition yes she started laughing
while i was doing a transition how dare
you i could sense that when it's
happening i'll be looking this way and i
can hear her mocking me next time i'll
scowl yes
so are you hopeful that america is
getting better now that it's tuning out
the legacy media that's got to be good
right can i give a recommendation sure
cnn yes now that they're no longer the
cuomo national network yes thank god no
more fredo but
if every day could be new year's eve at
cnn yes it would just
every day there could be half in the bag
like we saw
anderson cooper like we saw don lemon
and especially andy cohen high five andy
cohen was saying i can't wait for bill
de blasio to like just vacate the scene
he got chastised but wasn't that the
best yeah it's actually right it's the
only thing that cnn does that's remotely
watchable
you know and it's oh you get and andy
cone's only on like once a year and
that's like that's it that's it and they
did you know i kind of missed kathy
griffin too
kathy griffin you know she was i mean
she was kind of entertaining until she
did that stupid thing susan how are you
i'm good how are you i'm doing great
yeah great well okay so andy cohen i
don't think he's being invited back next
year oh he'll be back
cnn likes to hear the cnn like this
controversy because it it it moved the
spotlight away from all the weirdness
and like they were like you know what do
you make of that cnn dead is it time to
just close up shop
isn't that kind of what the body
administration is doing changing the
narrative yeah do you think they would
be talking about january the 6th or
changing filibuster rules if let's say
the economy was firing on all solanders
let's say that there weren't inflation
problems or supply chain crises here and
there i just feel but i think it's
dangerous though because once you open
pandora's box and you've heard mcconnell
saying if you change the filibuster
rules we will defund planned parenthood
right there'll be stricter abortion laws
i just think you have to be very careful
in terms of what you're doing up there
it's weird it's like they have amnesia
it's like they don't think that this
could actually be used against them yes
you know it's like it is a hey let's do
it now and then it gets goes bad for
them later cat
does that meet your expectations as a
question
it was an excellent question
uh really great i just i i think it's
strange to you know i
it's one thing to say hey you know we're
not relating to people but also it's i
think it's the preaching more than the
relating i think it's that you i can
listen to something that i'm not
perfectly interested in and like make a
nice face i think we can all do that as
humans like oh okay maybe i learned
something and then move on with your day
but it's the telling you how to live
your life and that the way you live your
life is wrong uh if you don't want to
get you know a new vaccine booster like
every three months or like you can't go
to a restaurant or if you know you for
your mask slips below your nose when
you're going out of the house that
you're a murderer like nobody wants to
watch something that's repeatedly
telling you what a horrible person you
are for wanting to do normal human
things yeah and that was that's what
cnn's become it's become the the i hate
you network
we're returning the favor
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else